je suis heureux d'annoncer que juillet
2019 on annonce en grande pompe le
financement du prolongement de la ligne
bleue
le projet de 6 km comprend cinq
nouvelles stations et doit relier le
métro saint michel aux galeries d'anjou
après 40 ans d'attentes l'est de
montréal pouvait enfin y croire mais
moins de deux ans plus tard québec
confirme qu'il est approprié de procéder
à une révision du projet c'est le
parcours du combattant
la facture estimée est passé de 4
milliards et demi à 6 milliards de
dollars 5 sans expropriation sont à
faire et le coût des terrains a explosé
les compensations aux propriétaires sont
imposés par le tribunal et elle
s'annonce élevée on avait évalué autour
de 300 millions de coûts de l'ensemble
des terrains long les rendus au dessus
d'un milliard la surchauffe du marché
vous en parlait souvent nouvelle tout
coûte plus cher que ce soit pour vous
construire une maison à l'image ni pour
construire un métro alors soit aussi
folle anticiper les mesures sanitaires
sa demande les coûts des chantiers
n'empêche que les comparaisons inquiète
quand on parle de la ligne bleue le
prolongement du métro de laval a coûté
150 3 millions de $ du kilomètre
celui de la ligne 52 du métro
d'amsterdam 450 millions la ligne 1 du
métro de paris est évalué à 420 millions
du kilomètre la ligne bleue elle risque
de coûter un milliard de $ du kilomètre
si j'enlève les frais financiers si
j'enlève le terrain de stationnement
incitatif si j'enlève les terminaux et
au dos si j'enlève tout ce qui est texte
tout ce qui n'est pas comparable dans
tous les projets on arrive à une moyenne
inférieure à la moyenne internationale
des dernières années pour de même type
de construction
c'est quand même trop cher aux yeux de
québec qu'il était dernier a donné trois
semaines à la stm pour proposer d'autres
scénarios
parmi ceux présentés celui de retirer 1
kilomètres de tunnels et la station
anjou des économies de 500 millions de
dollars les économies sont pas si
grandes parce qu'il faut quand même
faire un garage au bout de ligne etc
si on fait que cas station m'annonce
prix de tout le développement économique
potentiel qu'on a on joue faut pas qu'il
y ait moins de stations des cinq
stations sont primordiales c'est
important qu'on les mettre en place
mais comment est-ce qu'on peut sauver ou
pédaler coup absolument
la ville propose donc de faire des
compromis
faire une croix sur le terminus
d'autobus pie-ix réduire le nombre des
dix culot station et éliminer le
stationnement incitatif de 1200 places
aux galeries d'anjou
donc faut qu'on fasse réfléchir comment
on peut davantage amener des autobus qui
viendraient est des banlieues montréal
propose aussi de repenser les stations
pour permettre la construction de 2500
logements aux déçus il serait alors
possible qui la ville de vendre des
droits aériens au promoteur générer des
profits en faisant de la construction
par la suite
et moi je pense à syntec absolument dans
la logique que l'on a c'est à dire de
comptes de densifier autour du transport
collectif
la ville pense que ces suggestions
pourrait faire économiser plusieurs
centaines de millions de dollars
la table est donc mise pour les trois
mois de
discussions du groupe d'experts la
version finale du projet sera connu cet
été et la stm estime qu'une inauguration
est envisageable en 2027
mais s'il y a des sceptiques on peut les
comprendre ici jean-sébastien cloutier
radio-canada m'ont rien